il n'y a plus aucun doute sur le lien
entre l'exposition aux pesticides et le
développement de certaines maladies
des chercheurs de l'inserm ont compilé
plus de 5000 études dans le monde pour
les agriculteurs qui manipule ses
produits ou les riverains qui vivent à
proximité de champs ce qui apparaît
clairement c'est le lien entre
pesticides et plusieurs pathologies
comme la maladie de parkinson
le myélome ou le lymphome non hodgkinien
selon ce rapport la présomption d'un
lien est forte notamment pour certains
cancers chez l'enfant comme la leucémie
quand la mère a été exposée aux
pesticides pendant sa grossesse pour le
glyphosate le niveau de présomption est
moins élevé mais bien réelle avec le
développement de certains de lymphome
l'herbicide et pourtant toujours utilisé
en france avec notre président de la
république on a eu un peu tous les sons
de cloche on l'a entendu dire en 2017
qu'il fallait sortir du glyphosate et au
plus tard en trois ans c'est à dire au
plus tard en 2020 2021 et dernière il
est revenu sur cette décision et
maintenant on a effectivement plutôt une
stratégie qui vise à interdire certains
usages et pas d'autres ce qui veut bien
dire que là on n'est pas sur une logique
de protection de la santé pour le
chlordécone un insecticide largement
utilisé jusque dans les années 70 aux
antilles dans les bananeraies une
présomption d'un lien fort avec le
cancer de la prostate est avérée pour
les populations rurales exposés
régulièrement à ces produits
le sujet est donc plus que jamais un
enjeu de santé publique